let's get an update on Bobo sky John who
didn't like him called in and started
something called the hashtag unfollow
Bobo movement on Twitter a couple of
celebrities have endorsed Bobo Michael
Rapaport being one Nikki Glaser Glaser
Bobo fan Nikki Glaser has rethought her
position and she is now also unfollowing
just so happens that Nikki Glaser was in
the hallway she's here in the green room
do you want to ask her why right I'll
bring Nikki in Bobo if you want one of
the great beauties in show business
Nikki Glaser oh my gosh earlier this
morning a guy named John started hashtag
unfollow Bobo on Twitter
I was listening and you got upset you
felt you loved Bobo about his family
suffering because of this right his
children and his wife having to hear
about this all day I wanted to follow
him just for them yeah well the word we
got is you have unfollowed Bobo well i
unsolder than i followed quickly again
I'm just I'm on the fence Bobo I love
you so much you're a roaster you know
how to give people the business you
follow you unfollow it seems like you
just can't get your [ __ ] together on
this then I went back and looked at his
feed and I go let me just see if there's
anything here worth following right and
there truly isn't I mean you just
retweet things Bobo you're not doing a
lot of original content then you said I
would ask for a cease and desist and I
really wanted so badly for you to
misspell that but it was like correctly
written and it disappointed me as a Bobo
fan he doesn't know that Turman you know
that he said something where did you get
peace and desist from yeah yeah Nicky
I'm gonna give an update now Bob are you
sitting down no all right
Bobo you are down 2500 followers hashtag
unfollow now this is a travesty and this
nun world
Travis Dean it's a train I think it's a
tangerine tangerine yeah so you're gonna
keep following Bobo I keep going back
and forth I don't know how it is when
you see people who are going to the
polls and they still haven't decided how
to sticker for what I really decide you
know Pleiades have to have a strong
point of view and you are waiver weird
for right now I am following but you got
to step up your game I want you to write
like you talked I want you to give us
what we get on this show which is you
don't want his sounds matter yeah right
I want Bobo to be real Ralph wants to
convince you to follow know there's lots
of reasons I follow Bobo but mainly he
talked about himself in the third person
I mean that is so douchey come on right
yeah Nicky doesn't like that
[Laughter]
okay I need more though Ralph I know
it's fun but why hurt this man because
you know it drives them crazy come on
it's funny you can watch his numbers
tick down you know Nicky you did one of
the best ten minutes ever saw on Caitlyn
Jenner at the roast and yet you seem to
have compassion for bobo it is you're
right because i always justified the
rose because they sign up for it but you
know what Bobo you signed up for this
and I'm I'm gonna give you an unfollow
as soon as I get it's probably in my my
jacket Wow here's a celebrity Bob oh
it's very important to maintain the
celebrities because they are influenced
I feel if Bobo loses Nicki okay here we
go
what's happening I'm so sorry
okay let's go to Bobo H Stern and we are
currently following and unfollow Bobo I
just saw it oh my god my phone just got
more memory unfollow heard round the
world 14 minutes ago oh my god you can't
be here if you have a show I know but
come on now I don't know what the count
does you want your tote right now yeah
oh boy there's gonna be so weekend good
all right
all right here's Gary with the tote come
on hit it 2,600 for you it's you're
bringing so many people so much joy
right now in unfollowing you
so that's that's because of you buddy
good for you Nicky this is that's a
positive it really is fun